Governor Bush: Traditional public schools
knock it out of the park in many places.
My guess is they'll continue to thrive the
ones that are good.
And when you give parents choices, all schools
get better.
They don't get worse.
They get better.
Nat: Governor Bush, thanks for joining
us here at AEI.
Governor Bush: You bet, Nat.
Nat: So, I wanna sort of get to school
choice in a minute, which is sort of my bailiwick,
but I'm curious to get into a little of your
deep background as governor.
When you were governor, you did have big pushes
on school choice, but you also had the A+
Plan, which had a lot of the hallmarks of,
what we think of as accountability today.
But back before, it was cool.
So, can you just give me a thumbnail on that
and what do you think were some of the biggest
successes from that early accountability?
Governor Bush: Well, this will sound like
a bygone era, but when I ran for governor,
I laid out what I wanted to do in education.
I actually laid out the A+ Plan in detail.
It became the prominent dominant issue of
the campaign.
My opponent attacked me for it.
I defended it.
I won, and it gave me a mandate to do it,
which is a lesson that I think policymakers
and elected officials should remind themselves
of from time to time.
Nat: And you were able to do it fairly
quickly, right?
Governor Bush: First-year most of it.
So I went to visit 250 schools, kind of dehorn
myself because I've always believed in vouchers,
which at the time was, you know, very dangerous
apparently.
So the A+ Plan was we would grade schools
based on student learning A, B, C, D, and
F. And if a school was an F, they would be
given a voucher if they were F two years out
of four.
And if they showed improvement, they would
get $100 per student directly to the school,
no cut for the state or the school district.
We eliminated social promotion, and the next
year we created the opportunity scholarship
program, the corporate tax scholarship program,
and the McKay Scholarship Program, which were
the first statewide voucher programs, kind
of all within a two and three year period.
And it was a big damn deal.
I mean, it was tumultuous to say the least.
And the lessons learned were that you've gotta,
A, fan your priorities first.
You can't have provocative policy without
backing it up with money.
Two, you've gotta not just create in terms
of accountability.
You can't just say, "Here are our expectations.
Now go do it."
You gotta help people that have never actually
been held to account, and so we focused on
struggling schools and providing resources.
And the system adapted to this in a dramatic
way.
Nat: One of my key questions is you
put in a particular pretty toothsome requirement
that if third graders couldn't pass their
reading benchmarks, they weren't going to
fourth grade.
And I'm curious about how that works in a
large part because I see in a number of places,
we have really lofty ambitions and instead
of seeing sort of toothsome requirements,
oftentimes, we see people budding their[SP]
numbers to get, you know, sort of the numbers
[crosstalk 00:03:08] .
Governor Bush: You have exceptions that are
Mack truck wide.
Nat: Yeah, exactly, so how would that
go?
That's the first question, how'd that go.
It sounds like [crosstalk 00:03:14].
Governor Bush: We went from 32% of students
being level one, which I would call functional
illiterate, below basic readers, to 14% in
a two year periods.
But we had 14% of our kids held back in the
second year, which is, you know, it's a pretty
provocative idea.
But the net result was that...so we created
this gate, and so we're not kidding.
We're not gonna have big Mack truck wide exemptions.
But we did summer school again.
We put reading coaches in every school to
teach teachers how to teach reading.
We gave reading certificates to teachers to
get an additional pay.
We implemented early childhood education,
all of which, you know, together created improved
literacy and lower a number of functionally
illiterate kids.
It was in my reelection effort where had we
not made those appreciable gains that I described,
had we maintained the status quo, had nothing
changed, it would have been, you know, 25%
or 30% of all third graders stuck in third
grade.
That would have been really ugly.
Nat: You know, since then, there's
been a lot of accountability water under the
bridge.
We've had No Child Left Behind.
We've had the Obama era waivers, Race to the
Top.
Now we're at ESSA.
We've had Common Core.
There's so many things.
Knowing what you know now and have learned
about these lessons, what do you wish that
you had known back when you passed A+ that
you didn't know then?
Governor Bush: You know, the A+ Plan worked.
In reality, there were imperfections for sure,
but it worked.
So, one of the things that was so helpful
was that we built a database in our state.
Researchers use it all the time to kind of
study education outcomes on a longitudinal
basis.
We were blessed with a data bank that allowed
us to adjust and kind of anticipate where
we would go.
So cut scores kind of turned out to be important
in accountability.
Nat: Yeah, they do, huh?
Governor Bush: Yeah, really important.
And if you can kind of anticipate where you
go so that you don't have a...you have a bell
curve instead of everybody's an A or everybody's
an F, that's important.
And we had good data to be able to move us
towards, you know, rising student achievement.
Along the way, there was a lot of wavering,
not so much in my administration but after,
you know, there's always a reason not to move
it up a notch.
You know, we've basically I think as a nation,
we had some significant gains, not because
of me, but during my time as governor, many
states had gains.
Now we've seen a kind of a flatlining because
there's a push against accountability principally
because testing is, you know, bad, I guess,
from the minds of people.
And the reason is that we overtest.
There's all sorts of tests that local school
districts require that are part of the statewide
accountability system in these states.
And it's almost as long as it's designed to
like end up...You know, we're really hurting
accountability.
So our foundation advocates fewer tests, more
relevant tests, and more information from
those tests to turn it into a diagnostic tool.
Nat: That's interesting.
Let me ask you this, sort of juxtaposition
as a bridge to the talk about choice programs.
A lot of public school accountability could
be seen as increasing regulation on public
schools.
And then, on the other hand, we have private
school choice proposals.
And a lot of the times we say, "You know,
we need a light regulatory touch here."
How can you explain to people why you can
hold both those things in your hands at the
same time?
Governor Bush: I don't think accountability
is regulation.
Regulation is the number of, you know, cafeteria
workers you have to have per X number of students
or imposing another mandate on top of schools
because there was an isolated tragic case
of whatever.
That's the state mandates that local school
districts are very right to complain about.
Accountability is actually liberating people.
You know, we tried to create an environment.
Look, we want rising student achievement,
and here's how we're gonna measure it.
You go out and do your work and we'll fund
it and we'll help you.
So, I would distinguish between traditional
education regulation and accountability.
Now, the private...there is a friction in
school choice programs, the private programs
because you don't wanna impose rules on top
of private schools to make them basically
look like traditional public schools.
And we've always struggled what to do.
Do you test if someone takes public money?
Do you disclose it when there's only 10 kids?
You know, there's a lot of details in this
and nuance that gets worked out different
ways by states.
But the basic premise is that you're transposing
this top-down bureaucracy and rulemaking process
that's been around for 100 years in the traditional
public schools to parents to make this decision
for themselves.
As long as you give them the right information
and they know how their kid is doing, I think
that that's appropriate.
Nat: Right.
You support a number of private school choice
programs, all of them and you support charters
as well.
I have a lot of folks who really like charter
schools and they say, "You know what, charters
are enough.
Charters are enough.
We don't need these private school choice
programs."
What would you say to them?
Why would you say we do need private schools?
Governor Bush: I've met a lot of people that
are, you know, love high-performing charter
schools in the inner city, and there are some
phenomenal schools that just really hit it
out of the park, but it's not a zero-sum game.
Advocating support of archdiocese schools
in New York City does not hurt Success Academy.
It's truly not a question of one or the other.
In fact, they live side-by-side, and if they're
both flourishing, all the better.
Nat: So we just had this event upstairs
talking about Education Savings Accounts,
which I've spent a great deal of time studying.
I wanna ask you a couple of questions about
those, but for the viewers that may not know
what they are can you just kind of describe
them?
Governor Bush: Well, they vary, but they're
basically accounts that parents receive.
They receive literally an account of money
depending on what's appropriated to be able
to choose going to a private school or to
break it up, disaggregate it as you said upstairs,
big word.
Nat: Yeah.
We like big words around here.
It's the main thing.
Governor Bush: Hey, I know.
Tutoring, you know, after-school programs,
all sorts of other uses.
In Florida, the principle ESA program that
is really successful is the Gardiner Scholarship
Program named after the former president of
the state senate who was the sponsor of the
bill.
And now 10,000 parents or students, their
parents get to choose from...they get I think
up to $10,000.
So it's a robust amount of money, and it can
be to keep your child in the school, a traditional
public school but get additional services.
Those services, by the way, under the federal
law should be provided.
But as you might know, the federal law isn't
always implemented in a faithful way.
And a lot of parents are very frustrated that
the public schools don't...their individual
education plan that the law requires be met
isn't being met.
So this is a way for them to take that power
and implement it on their own.
Nat: Sure.
And ESAs, our education savings accounts,
ESAs are sort of the new kid on the block
as far as it comes to choice programs.
We have tax credits scholarships, and so I
know we have voucher, traditional voucher
programs.
What is it that they bring that is just totally
different than these other forms?
Governor Bush: The main difference is that
you're empowering...the money goes to parents
to choose how they spend it on behalf of their
children.
You know, there's restrictions, of course.
But it's different than a kind of a binary
choice of going to the traditional school
that your kid was already going to or a private
option.
ESAs give you the choice of going to a private
school, staying in a public school and using
private services along the way.
So it's a much more dynamic flexible tool
for parents to help their children learn.
Nat: Yeah, that's interesting.
It raises the question of the supply side.
We can do a lot about the demand side by giving
families money and ways to use it that they
otherwise wouldn't.
But it's sort of harder to develop a supply
side of providers who are gonna kind of meet
those demands.
If you just have school choice, well, it's
obvious that schools rise up.
With ESAs, you need all kinds of different
providers.
What have you seen in Florida and in other
states in your work with the Foundation for
Excellence in Education that give you the
confidence that the supply side will respond?
Governor Bush: Well, supplies or supply side
always responds to demand.
I mean, it's kind of how free-market economics
work.
Unfortunately, this is not a free market in
the sense that if there's, you know, capital
costs or really principal cost for developing
private alternatives.
And there you have to be creative and so if,
you know, you gotta raise capital, you have
to identify buildings and provide support
for that, it's a challenge.
But ultimately, what we found was that as
our corporate tax scholarship program, McKay
Scholarship Program, Gardiner Scholarship
Program went from literally zero to now 150,000
students that new schools were formed and
supply ultimately met the need.
And there's still big waiting lists of kids
that are trying to get into these programs.
Nat: Right.
Now, a lot of these programs are gonna be
state programs, but they're gonna run into
the school finance structure, which is we
have local dollars.
I've got some dollars from my state, and across
the nation, there's about 10% federal funding,
45% state, 45% local.
Well, if you're state making rules with 45%
of your money to try and provide real educational
opportunities for kids, you're stuck in a
pretty good jam if you can't come up with
the funds to give people a valuable voucher
or ESA.
Can you just speak to that challenge?
Governor Bush: Sure.
In the case of our programs, the principal,
the largest voucher program is the corporate
tax scholarship program, and it's less per
student than the traditional public school
option.
So, in effect, every child that leaves the
public school to go to the private school
is saving the state money, and there's a growing
understanding of that which sustains these
programs.
So on the one hand, you're...And in Florida,
we have a merging of our local and state funding,
which just makes this much easier.
Nat: Yeah, it does.
Governor Bush: So, in the states that don't
have that, you're gonna have to appropriate
money.
The Gardiner Program is a separate line item
in appropriation, which gets to the basic
point.
If it's a high priority, it ought to be first
funded.
You know, Washington doesn't work this way,
but most states if a governor says, "This
is my number one priority," you take the first
monies to fund your first priorities, and
so we never...we weren't constrained.
Other states, you know, where it's a big fight
in the legislature, really are hampered by
this for sure.
Nat: I'm gonna ask you a question
from your perspective as head of the Foundation
for Excellence in Education, so can you just
tell our viewers what is the foundation and
what's its mission?
Governor Bush: Sure.
It was formed in 2007.
It started as a place where we could tell
the Florida story, which is really a story
of choice, accountability, and a focus on
early childhood literacy and the combination
of all this yielding rising student achievement,
which is ultimately what matters.
But we've morphed into still telling that
story, and we go state-by-state to policymakers
in the legislature and in the executive branch
kind of forewarning them of the mistakes that
we might have made, which is always helpful,
not to remake the mistakes that others have
made and encouraging them to be big and bold
and providing support when they do and then
helping them and guide them on implementation.
This is complex stuff, so whether it's testing
or just basically the science of reading or
making sure that accountability system is
done the right way where it's not gonna blow
up in your face the next year.
We've had states that have ignored our advice
in that regard and it blew up in the next
year and they had to start over.
We wanna be a trusted adviser.
We don't bigdog it, you know, show up at a
place and take credit.
We operate typically with business, with chambers,
and with local and state-based policy institutes
to do this in partnership always being deferential
to the leaders that take the...you know, to
have to do the courageous thing which is to
advocate whether you're a governor or a member
of the legislature.
Nat: Sure.
So taking Florida off the table for obvious
reasons, what other state is just knocking
out of the park in terms of education, generally,
but private school choice programs charters?
Who do you think's really doing great?
Governor Bush: I'd say Arizona has a robust
charter school program in a burgeoning private
school program.
Governor Ducey is a big and bold leader.
Brian Sandoval did something extraordinary,
but you know the legislature changed and I
don't think he got it off the ground to make
it completely sustainable because there's
not enough scale yet.
But he had a full-throated ESA.
Wow, I mean that's the ultimate thing.
So huge credit for making that big first step.
Indiana has...it's kind of followed the footsteps
of Florida and done some things even bigger.
Louisiana, although...you know there's...every
state kind of ebbs and flows.
Tennessee has had big learning gains with
a focus on teacher preparation and public
school choice.
So there are some good states out there.
Colorado is a place where actually bipartisan
consensus has emerged from time to time, is
one of the few states where there's not a...
Nat: That still exist?
Governor Bush: Yeah.
Well, apparently in Colorado.
It's the water up there or maybe that new
initiative that they've passed [crosstalk
00:18:02]
Nat: It's the elevation, maybe.
I don't know.
Governor Bush: Every state's different.
You know, Mississippi's a place where starting
really from nothing, Governor Bryant's done
a really good job of...they've passed or they're
passing an ESA.
There's big support in the business community
and in the political leadership for meaningful
efforts there, and they're focused on reading.
They didn't have a charter school program
until recently.
So depending on where you are on the spectrum
of change, you know, these are big steps.
And we help each state kind of uniquely based
on where they are.
Nat: So, you support vouchers.
You support online education.
You support ESAs, charter schools.
And these are all worthy of support, but they
all do inevitably leave students away from
traditional school districts and neighborhood
schools.
A lot of people will say, "Well, you know,
that's because you hate neighborhood districts
and traditional public schools."
If that's not the case, you know, as these
things grow and they succeed, what do you
see is the future for traditional school districts
and neighborhood schools?
Governor Bush: Well, neighborhood schools
particularly I think are going away because
they have broad support among moms and dads
just because of the convenience and the safety
factor.
Parents have lots of reasons why they support
their children going to particular schools.
It's not always the way the bing counters
and the bureaucrats suggest.
And so, traditional public schools will always
be well-funded.
Will there be a little bit of, you know, stress
because the long-term pension obligations,
the sins of the past put pressure on school
districts?
Yeah, but so what, you know.
I mean, if you go to some states, more money's
being spent to deal with the pension obligations
decided 20 years ago.
Classroom education has languished even though
they spend double what a state like Florida
spends.
Is that fair, the fact that we were more disciplined
and in how we went about it.
Should we bemoan the fact that states are
gonna have to make some adjustments?
No, I mean, that's part of what I think is
an important element of a 21st century education
system, to move away from this industrial
model that is failed in the private sector
and would have failed already in the public
sector had it not been for all of us paying
our taxes to sustain something that's not
as efficient as it needs to be.
But traditional public schools knock it out
of the park in many places.
And my guess is they'll continue to thrive
the ones that are good.
And when you give parents choices, all schools
get better.
They don't get worse, they get better.
Nat: So, there's a number of private
school or just choice options, right?
There's public school choice and charters.
We have ESA's tax credits scholarships vouchers
and a number of different kinds of programs.
So let me present you with a false forced
choice.
If you had to choose one to bet on, what's
your favorite program of these?
Governor Bush: I mean, if you created a statewide
ESA program and you created a repository of
options for parents and there was some degree
of transparency about their effectiveness
and what the price was and all the things
that a consumer of something of that importance
would need and you had accountability around
it which would be different than the traditional
accountability so that parents would know
what was working and what wasn't.
That to me would be the ideal situation.
I mean, if a girl could dream, it would be
to turn parents, well-informed parents with
accurate transparent information into the
school districts.
Nat: Yeah, it's a little bit of a
chicken and the egg thing.
Of course, you can't have a vibrant marketplace
of educational service providers without developing
an information system that gives feedback
to consumers.
And, of course, you can't get that system
up until you have the vibrant system.
But what do you think states should think
about as they're trying to develop that and
trying to just grease those gears?
Governor Bush: I think that's what they need
to think about is if you pass a voucher bill
or expanded charter, any expansion of parental,
the parents are ultimately accountable for
their children's education you've gotta along
the way, at the same time, simultaneously
give them a system of real information.
You know, as I mentioned upstairs, that's
a place where generally the governments have
failed.
They just don't think that way.
They are insular in their nature.
They've never had to market.
You know, they never had to actually learn
how to present something in a way that a mom
and a dad would understand how they're doing.
In fact, in some cases, they don't want you
to know because, you know, if kids aren't
learning, it's not like a great conversation.
Nat: That's true, that's true.
Keep it quiet.
Indeed.
Governor Bush: Well, how you get to the place
where, you know, you have someone graduating
with a high school diploma with an 8th-grade
level reading capability.
How do you get to the point where a significant
percentage, 40, 50% of kids are college and/or
career ready?
More than that actually they have to retake...if
they go to college, they have to retake high
school reading and high school math.
The only way you do it is that you've kept
it quiet because no mom would say, "Well,
that's great.
My little Johnny went 12 years and he's a
9th-grade reader, woohoo."
Nat: Yeah, not a lot to cheer about.
Let me ask you about advice for legislators
or governors that are trying to develop an
ESA in their state.
Now, of course, these are gonna go through
the push and pull of making legislation sausage-making,
and they have to compromise, sometimes on
price, sometimes on how many people are eligible,
sometimes on what kind of regulation they're
gonna cover.
Where would you say if you're developing an
ESA bill you can't compromise on?
Where can they not afford to compromise on?
Governor Bush: I think it's making sure that
there's going to be private providers opting
in, which means price.
It would be better to cap the number and go
back to fight again the next session of raising
the cap but making sure that this amount of
money while lower than the per student public
school it always should be lower than that.
But it's enough to be able to attract high-quality
providers into the arena.
Nat: And so why would you say it should
always be lower quality?
Not lower quality, a lower amount of money
then what is spent in the local public schools
as I just following up on that.
Governor Bush: Why?
Because any transformation, you know, in life
outside of government innovation normally
cost less and yields a better result.
And we should apply that model I think rather
than the tidal model that cost more money.
More money isn't the leading indicator of
a better result and plus politically, if you're
gonna go propose...I got this great idea,
I'm gonna propose a voucher that is double
the cost of 50% more or 25% more than the
per-student funding, by the way, because it's
private, we're not gonna impose all these
rules on top of them.
So, you know, we don't know exactly if it's
gonna be perfect.
You're not gonna get that passed in the state
legislature.
Nat: A number of people that I know
or I'm familiar with, they will criticize
private school choice programs on equity grounds.
They will say, "Well, you know, this is...the
people who are gonna take advantage of this
are disproportionately white or rich or something
else."
Governor Bush: The private school choice programs?
Nat: Yes.
And so how do you respond when you hear arguments
like that?
Governor Bush: It's just not true.
It's not true at all.
Every data point suggests otherwise.
Most of these programs are taken advantage
of by lower-income people.
The programs for children with learning disabilities
are pretty, you know, across the spectrum,
both higher income and lower income, but there's
no disproportionate that I'm aware of whether
it's charter schools or private voucher programs.
The exact opposite is true that people, because
of how the programs are typically crafted,
people of lower-income benefit from these
programs.
The issue that I think is important is to
make sure that parents that are...you know,
a single mom that's struggling with two jobs
and sees this as a chance for their child
to rise up and to be successful to go to a
private school that they're informed, they
get the proper information, you know.
That to me is a bigger issue.
If you're in a more affluent area and you
have the information available and you can
seek it out and, you know, you have a network
of community that can just kind of by the
tom-toms tell you what teacher is good, what
school is good.
If you don't have all that, then I think it's
the obligation of the state to provide that
information to level out the playing field.
Nat: So private school choice has
a friend in the White House and at the Department
of Education that they never really had.
You know, charters had support from the administration
before but not private school choice.
But private school choice has grown in state
capital after state capital, it has not been
Washington DC that's been pushing it.
So do you think that this new support from
the administration is gonna be a change in
that and how might states, you know, make
good on that new support in DC?
Governor Bush: Well, it could be that there's
a...there'd be a federal voucher program emerge
in the welfare reform, the fight against poverty
that emerges in Paul Ryan's world next...this
year.
I don't know.
That would be wonderful to include it because
empowering parents that are near at the poverty
level with more choices in education would
be a key element of that.
I'm a little wary of it only in that it should
not hurt the existing choice programs that
exist across the country.
It should enhance them.
There should be enough flexibility that if
the federal government wants to provide support
which states that already have these voucher
programs and school choice programs would
love to have, it shouldn't be with so many
strings attached that it stifles the work
that's already being done.
So my guess is that we'll continue on this
path that this is really a state issue locally
administered.
The federal government has...with Betsy DeVos,
certainly is a strong advocate of accelerating
school choice programs across the country
and hopefully, she could be a partner.
But I cannot imagine a time when the Trump
administration with Secretary DeVos' input
at least would make it harder for the existing
choice programs to prevail.
Nat: Jeb Bush, thanks for coming to
AEI and talk about us.
Governor Bush: You bet.
Thanks.
Nat: Hey, everyone, that's the end
of our discussion with Governor Jeb Bush.
Thanks for watching.
As always, let us know what other topics you'd
like AEI scholars to cover on Viewpoint.
And to learn more about Education Savings
Accounts, check the links in the description
below.